hey all I just wanted to say thank you
for putting up with this past week I
haven't done a lot of videos it's been
chaotic I thoroughly will make it up to
you guys
haider me hmm um I'll thoroughly make it
up to you guys
I plan on here me did you guys hear that
Wow yeah I seriously know far be it for
me to say I know everything which I do I
know how it is I mean join the club
that's not funny
it's kind of funny and thunders really
actually you when you're pissed I die
I couldn't have called that I thought
the scientists totally totally nailed
that one yeah I do it for a fact
pretty cool it is cool I'd do it if I
could I mean they probably would too
yeah no no person's job you know enough
about that if you really want to make it
up to your fans just give them what they
want
filming Blake Lively and Christina
Hendricks drunk in a room together while
they stop talking all right I know where
you were going with that and that is
awesome Wow seriously him too why does
he talk like Gollum with a smoking
disorder same reason that you Thunder
effect that's weird
all right you stop talking you listen
yeah yeah Jeremy just do the people that
they've been screaming for in the
comments sections of your videos and
your personal messages okay all right
here's a subscriber of yours named Heath
awesome said quote you should review
older movies when you find the time and
you still haven't done I know I was
going to but and then a hundred and
forty seven people liked that comment a
hundred and forty seven seven I know I'm
going to you really think I spared you
from that freeway wipeout incident so
you could not give the people what they
want
I'm telling you I was going to it's all
part of the plan
who I was going to how often ever heard
that yeah and that guy was going to be
mr. awesome look how that turned out
alright that is just mean that they were
hungry and the fruit was there and it
looked good review older movies are
you're sleeping on a third floor yeah
with me that is from home alone to come
on yeah so yes seriously it's a classic
come on
Oh Jeremy not a John Hughes fan no I
didn't mean that oh no it's fine I'll
just go right over there Tommy you don't
like some of the funniest classics ever
made no I just honestly thoroughly
disappointed right now seriously no
class no class seriously you're gonna
say no class oh no see
thank you yeah well you got me there so
come on review classics like Back to the
Future
Oh devil's advocate Lord of the Rings
Twilight always awesome oh maybe not
not Star Trek 5 or I will end your life
oh my gosh let it go man horribly
misrepresented me in that movie well it
wasn't actually supposed to be you in
the movies did you want to be alone
yeah well I still don't like it but they
so captured your eyes with that
lightning he does have a point though
nobody actually likes that one I get all
exactly how can you follow the whales
movie with that exactly all right all
right I see your point
I'm Morgan Freeman he nailed it that
makes a census he nailed Star Trek 5 I
mean in terms of someone being me
great I didn't I knew that I did love
that guy well I mean I gotta agree with
that I mean who doesn't
all right so give the people what they
want already all right I will I swear I
promise
scouts honor if I were a scout good and
I'll be back to check up on you go blow
this guy's mind with a triple rainbow
nice you already do that though no that
was actually a double rainbow but well
he was I Oh gotcha
Wow you are still here right now review
classics
that was a weird dream Wow they'll
really see the same thing when they wake
up it's not a dream do it okay I catch
you I got you you told me you guys
wanted it you apparently got Yahweh
involved so here they come